fly her to indianapolis
keep your mama comfortable like a
[ __ ]
did you move to indianapolis i live in
indianapolis oh yeah oh you like it
there [ __ ] no
why why are you there then my husband
works at general motors
and so that's what originally got me
there i'm getting ready to move back to
atlanta back to atlanta yeah yeah la was
never your thing i know i can't do this
oh oh carrie e ness place
fake titties and i can't do all of this
[ __ ] yeah you got to be all these
lunches y'all doing all these dreams
maker
dream killers and fake [ __ ] and
everybody playing like they
opportunities yeah i can't do that [ __ ]
these are worse than prostitutes
let me ask you something i got the wrong
attitude i'm like get the [ __ ] out of my
face you're lying [ __ ] yeah
miss pat
do you think that's that's just a
perception thing or do you think that's
a real like i understand that they're
just to hear me out right i understand
people's like um
feelings toward people they have the
opinions about people in la and they
think it's like she's talking about
she's not wrong about the industry the
industry is like but it's like that let
me argue this though it's like that in
any business
like if you're if you're climbing the
corporate ladder in any corporation in
like
atlanta or new york or whatever right
depending on what it is people backstab
each other and they climb to the top and
then do lunches it's like everybody here
doing something everybody's in
opportunities i mean if you had a
corporate ratio and it says 100 people
everybody ain't opportunities you got
some real people just it's like here if
you put 10 [ __ ] together in the
business nine of them will step on your
head to get to the top that's true so
it's just it's that's what i'm talking
about you know everybody because
everybody wants to be famous everybody
can't be famous somebody got to sit at
home and watch the other [ __ ]
that's true okay yeah everybody can't be
on tv everybody ain't got a talent yeah
but you can't tell these [ __ ]
they ain't got to tell them with social
media now d i mean i remember when i
first started coming out to l.a and i
would see actors that could not make it
standing on stage to do comedy why [ __ ]
why take up the space that you should
not be in if you don't get your stupid
ass off that stage you probably ain't a
good actor but i know you're not a good
comedian yeah yeah and that's what
really burns me when i see a a broke ass
actor trying to be a comedian if you
don't get the [ __ ] out of space when we
already broke over here and gotta we
need this little [ __ ] stage
time so somebody can take us on the road
so we can buy a baloney sandwich
yeah the [ __ ] off that goddamn stage i
mean i i'm just they're like oh that
person is active but they're doing
comedy that that's not a comedian yeah
does the [ __ ] come to me comedy come
from tragedy
struggles life issues and hugs
it's got to be here yeah if you ever do
this [ __ ] for the money you're never
going to make it yeah but here's what
when i see i see those [ __ ] all
the time right i'm quite sure you do
that's won't live here yeah but here's
the thing when i see them though what
you do i know that
what it takes to get to you know i mean
headline and get a
fan base and all that
is you need to
they're not i already know that they're
not going to be able to do the steps and
the ability to get through all the gates
to get to where we're at so i just don't
mind them i get that they're stealing
our stage time i don't worry about him
either i just noticed i'm like he got
this [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah what tick tick
blood sucking [ __ ] stage sucker
[ __ ]
they're ticks yeah
yeah you're right i mean um and then six
months later they don't they're not even
doing it no more yeah or they just hang
you know that's that's the [ __ ] i'm
talking about yeah but i'm glad you know
what i love about stand up and even the
show this shows business in general it's
so hard it's so [ __ ] it's so hard
that like honestly i've been in the game
well hello over 25 years
i now
feel like i think i'm making it
it took me this long before i would get
you know i was on mad tv but we didn't
get paid a lot we got like
you started off with 4 000 a week
with taxes and your agents everything
you're making
you're on a tv show you're on a tv show
and you're making
two thousand dollars a week
that everybody else think you're making
a [ __ ] ton yeah they think you are but
then you still have to get the clothes
to look right and all that stuff and
yeah i mean and it's like you're not
making any money i had to borrow money
man when i was on that show but it's
only now where i feel like
okay i'm get i'm getting offers on [ __ ]
um when i go on the road it sells out
yeah you know i see you yeah and this is
you know making me money and you know
and it's like i bought this house you
know i mean so it's beautiful yeah this
has only been a couple of years since i
could afford a house like this yeah yes
i'm feeling it too i mean yeah you're
killing it now too well i ain't killing
it like you but no you are noticed that
uh you know
my my
my touring is starting to pick up
um you know
um i'm able to do [ __ ] i really i
couldn't do two three years ago yeah so
you know it took five years to get this
tv show
out did you know i started out with fox
i went through three writers